♪♪
(Footsteps)
Allie:
We've made it.
♪♪
Everything's going to be
different from now on.
♪♪
Margot:
You want to make this a home,
whether we like it or not.
♪Children born to get high,
Turn your heads to the sky♪
♪♪
Isela:
It took a long time for this
place to find its footing.
♪♪
Isela:
And I took a very personal risk
bringing you here, Allie.
(Bell rings)
Please, don't make me regret
that choice.
♪♪
Allie:
You don't want to stay here with
me.
♪♪
Allie:
I just want to keep everyone
safe.
♪♪
Margot:
Look at you, thinking you've got
all the answers.
♪♪
♪Thor thunder crack your
hearing♪
♪♪
People don't change, Allie, they
just reveal themselves over
time.
♪♪
We need to leave.
Allie:
What's wrong?
It's something we can never come
back from.
♪♪
Margot's gonna be a problem.
Margot:
I've got to get us out of here.
You burn that bridge.
♪♪
Directory assistance.
Washington, DC.
Margot?
♪♪
Man on phone:
Why would I want to help you?
♪♪
Because if you do, I'll give you
what you want.
♪♪
♪Lookin' for the rain to fall♪